good morning believe nation today's
messages stand out from the crowd over
to you Leonardo DiCaprio do you remember
the audition when you first met an arrow
that was yeah I mean that was one of
those incredible auditions that came
around that I suppose every kid had been
waiting for for a long period of time
because it's just not that often that
you get a starring role above Robert De
Niro and this incredible you know
screenplay and was you know Ellen Barkin
and Michael Keaton Jones and was just
everyone was sort of feeding for this
role and I I got done I suppose to the
final five and there's like a last sort
of day Toby was there and I I do
remember thinking to myself I got to do
something I got to do something to stand
out and in the audition that was art
lence and Michael Keaton Jones art
Lata's that was the producer and DeNiro
and I remember there was a mustard jar
scene and he had to jam a mustard jar in
my eye repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and the script so didn't call for it but
I got up and I he said now is it empty
is it empty and I got up and I screamed
Oh like completely unnecessary but I
screamed in his face and I start there
you know with my head you know looking
like a red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me and then the
entire room the Niro everybody was in
hysterics i sat there frozen's thinking
oh my god I just screwed this entire
and I just sat there frozen and then you
know Bob and traditional DeNiro fashion
kind of just look to me wet and and then
you know we carried on doing the scene
and I think I actually had dinner with
DeNiro recently and he told me no I was
the one who said I was the one who said
you should get to get the job I love
this message I love this message so much
because I think people routinely pushed
down their genius you have opportunities
every single day to shine to show your
art to be creative to express yourself
to get better to improve your skills and
instead of letting that shine instead of
being yourself you worry about other
people's expectations and you deliver a
mediocre product or service to match
their expectations and more often than
not if you live your life to match
somebody else's expectations you're
diminishing your own and that's how most
people live most people are so afraid to
take a chance on something to be
themselves because they're afraid of
losing a client or they're afraid of
being rejected or they're afraid of how
they're gonna get judged where the
reality is that's how you're going to
shine if you want to do something great
if you want to have a big impact you
want to make meaningful change in
people's lives the only way it's gonna
happen is for you to be the best version
of you not on anybody else's version you
don't go into a career because your
parents want you to do this you don't
take on a new business because ink
magazine said it's a hot company to
start you do the thing that seems crazy
you do the thing that you're betting on
yourself that may not make sense right
now and in every opportunity every every
hour of the day you have chances to be
yourself or to be somebody else's
version of you and you need to train
that muscle to trust you to trust your
insta
to trust your gut to take the risk when
you feel afraid of how somebody else
might react to it to push through the
paint and do it anyway and not every
situation is gonna work out but if you
want to get to here with whatever your
goals and aspirations are the only way
to do it is if you release your genius
to stop pressuring it down and yes you
may lose some opportunities but you're
gonna win some big ones you're gonna
build a successful business you're gonna
make a meaningful impact on a lot of
people you're gonna make a lot of money
so the next time you feel that inner
edge to do things your way to say it say
something to speak up in a meeting to
inject your art into the next project
you're putting out take a chance and do
it trust your genius so the question of
the day today is I want to know the last
time you trusted your inner genius leave
it in the comments below I want to join
in the discussion see what you have to
say thank you guys so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot event special